el número de ejercicios en khan academy
se ha incrementado rápidamente desde que
inició en 2006 la relación entre el
tiempo transcurrido t en años eso es
importante déjame poner que estamos
hablando de un tiempo en años desde el
inicio de khan academy y el número total
de ejercicios y esta es la cantidad
total de ejercicios por año esta función
que depende del tiempo se modela con la
siguiente función el número total de
ejercicios por año que hay en la canaca
de ming es igual a 100 x 1.7 elevado a
la t ojo observa que aquí tenemos a t
expresada en años que tiene comunidades
los años completa la siguiente oración
sobre la tasa de cambio mensual eso
también es muy importante vamos a buscar
la tasa de cambio mensual del número de
ejercicios redondea la respuesta
a dos decimales cada mes el número de
ejercicios aumentan por un factor de y
bueno esto es lo que nos piden ojo si
estuviéramos hablando del factor por el
cual aumentan los ejercicios cada año
entonces sería muy fácil porque vemos
esta fórmula de aquí y decir cada vez
que aumentamos el tiempo en un año vamos
a aumentar esta cantidad en uno y por lo
tanto nuestro factor sería 1.7 estaremos
multiplicando por 1.7 ese sería nuestro
factor anual pero lo que queremos es
saber la tasa de cambio mensual y para
eso qué te parece si hacemos una pequeña
tabla que nos ayude a digerir todo este
problema voy a hacer una pequeña tabla
por aquí más o menos así así que aquí
voy a poner ate y por acá voy a poner a
a
de lujo y qué te parece si pensamos en
cuánto va a valer m es decir el número
total de ejercicios que teníamos cuando
te va al día 0 es decir me voy a fijar
en el número total de ejercicios que
teníamos en un inicio y bueno si
reemplazamos a t por 0 aquí me va a
quedar 100 x 1.7 elevado a cero esto se
va a ser 1 y simple y sencillamente me
voy a quedar con 100 estás de acuerdo
y bueno cuántos un mes a comparación de
un año bueno pues un mes es lo mismo que
un doceavo de año
doceavo de año estás acuerdo el año
tiene 12 meses me voy a tomar solamente
un mes de esos 12 meses
y bueno cuál va a ser el número total de
ejercicios después de un mes es decir el
número total de ejercicios mensuales
bueno pues vamos a sustituir aquí me va
a quedar 100 100 que multiplica a 1.7
esto elevado la potencia
doceavo y cuánto va a ser esto bueno
para eso vamos a sacar por aquí nuestra
calculadora y vamos a ver cuánto es 1.7
esto elevado a la potencia 1 sobre 12 y
eso va a ser lo mismo que 1.0 45 bueno
aproximadamente déjame ponerlo aquí esto
va a ser aproximadamente 100 100 que
multiplica a 1.0 45 muy bien y qué
pasaría después de otro mes si nos
fijamos un mes después bueno pues en el
segundo mes es decir después de que pase
un bimestre que obtendríamos bueno esto
sería lo mismo que 100 100 que
multiplica a 1.7 esto elevado a la 212 a
vos
a las 12 a vos lo cual sería exactamente
lo mismo que 100 si el que multiplica a
1.7 esto elevado al a un doceavo y esto
elevado a su vez al cuadrado es decir
estaríamos multiplicando por 1.7 elevado
a la un doceavo de nuevo o dicho otra
manera estaríamos multiplicando por 1.0
45 de nuevo una segunda vez o bueno otra
forma de verlo es que si quieres
replantear esta fórmula que tenemos aquí
pero esta vez utilizando los meses me
quedaría lo siguiente la cantidad o el
número total de ejercicios por mes y
esta función con respecto al tiempo ojo
aquí el tiempo está dado en meses eso va
a ser lo mismo que sí
si en que multiplica y esta vez no va a
ser 1.7 va a ser 1.7 elevado a la juntos
ya bo ha dicho otra manera 1.0 45 1.0 45
esto a su vez elevado a la t pero ojo
estate está te está dada en años
mientras que esta nueva tema déjame
ponerlo con este color
esta nueva te está dada en meses y bueno
puedo decir que aproximadamente porque
recuerda que aquí redondeamos un poco y
bueno ahora sí si queremos responder
esta pregunta que dice cada mes el
número de ejercicios aumenta por un
factor de y bueno podríamos decir 1.7
elevado a la un doceavo pero si queremos
la respuesta redondeada a dos decimales
entonces podemos decir que aumenta por
un factor d
punto 05 si redondeamos esta cantidad de
aquí a dos decimales así que ya está
esta es la respuesta correcta y nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo